David I hear often that the country is
more divided than ever but it's divided
for a good reason
one side is insane is it really that bad
for the country to be divided I think
it's important to answer this question
to understand that partisanship and
division are two different things and
I'm not saying the country isn't divided
but divided might point more towards the
types of circumstances that would lead
to a civil war right where half the
country wants to separate the south
wants to secede in order to maintain
states rights to have slavery be legal
for example we don't have that level of
division right now there are some
secessionist but not that many a lot of
us who say hey the red states want to
bail go ahead we are the financially
viable blue states we're sort of joking
I mean it would be extraordinarily
damaging to the country if the country
were to separate into financially even
if mathematically in the long run the
blue states would be fine and the red
states wouldn't it would be such a jolt
to the system that it would be very bad
for the economy for a while the
partisanship we are seeing is partially
because we are sort of coming to a
potentially big change in the path of
America and I don't want to excuse the
partisanship as merely sensible because
of this precipice we might be
approaching part of the reason we have
this partisanship is because of partisan
media including the existence of Fox
News and other right-wing media carrying
water in a way that doesn't relate to
the facts on the ground at all social
media echo chambers like there are some
really toxic reasons why we have such
partisanship that even though the
country has moved to the left a lot of
money is still raised by the right by
kind of hunkering down these extremist
reactionary positions on abortion and
immigrants and so on and so forth
so there's a lot of really horrible
reasons why we have partisanship but
also our system rewards partisanship
if you run centrist campaigns it becomes
harder to raise money for re-election
because you're not appealing to the
people who are most radical and I use
that term non-judgmentally when it comes
to issues
radical positions justify and encourage
more donations and that's part of the
system that we have but to some degree
the election of Donald Trump was insane
and now there is a question are are we
real acting Trump and saying Trump was
not an anomaly or an anomaly depending
on which pronunciation you like we are
we've had four years of Trump and we're
going to four more that would be a huge
thing for the country to do on the other
hand we have the possibility of electing
the most progressive presidents in the
history of the United States Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren even some of
the other candidates would be more
progressive than anyone else who has
been president so far so I believe that
the hyper partisanship in part is also
because of this precipice of possible
significant change that we're going to
have the media fomented the media
profits from it no question about it and
we are living in two different realities
Media foments that in part the Internet
is a huge part of it you have everything
from militant conspiracy theorists more
and more white supremacy far-right hyper
nationalist types there is increasingly
a lack of middle ground represented in
media social media reinforces more and
more extreme versions of whatever it is
that you believe or support and it's
extraordinarily powerful getting through
to people and saying let's be sensible
becomes difficult and often not rewarded
when when you look at polls about what
TV shows what podcasts what websites the
left and the right are looking at they
are very different and they are
increasingly ones that merely reinforce
and continue to radicalize that
pre-existing worldview so serious
division has many negative effects both
sides can be more easily controlled by a
minority of their side by picking the
issues that will most catalyze and
rational and a reactionary create
reactionary views and that can be done
in perpetuity to keep increasing the
division or partisanship the deepening
political divide can also lead to
violence we've talked about how many of
us believe if Donald Trump were to be
removed from office by losing in 2020
but claimed that it was unfair that it
was rigged in some way I fear that there
would be violence and hyper-partisanship
and division can also cause that but I
don't believe the country is so much
divided as it is hyper partisan which
comes with its own set of issues what do
you think is the country divided
hyper-partisan a little bit of both one
or the other I want to hear from you